[Musique]
le Salon de l'Agriculture internationale
se termine ce dimanche 5 mars et les
amoureux du territoire yvelinois ont
récolté une pluie de récompense sur 57
médailles 18 ont été remportés par des
producteurs des Yvelines on note
notamment la brasserie barge à
Rambouillet qui reçoit la médaille
d'argent pour sa bière blanche la ferme
de Viltain a Jouy-en-Josas récolte une
médaille d'or pour son yaourt au lait de
vache brassé à la vanille ou encore la
médaille d'argent pour le producteur de
Rome square box au Mureaux le club de
football de Versailles cherche un
nouveau stade en cas de montée en Ligue
2 arrivé en National l'été dernier le FC
Versailles évolue actuellement à Jean
Bouin mais la pelouse synthétique du
stade parisien ne correspond pas aux
normes de la deuxième division
professionnelle face à ces difficultés
les dirigeants versaillir réfléchissent
à une solution de repli l'équipe
pourrait être amenée à se délocaliser en
dehors de la région parisienne les
stades du Mans et de Villeneuve-d'Ascq
sont par exemple évoqués pour accueillir
les joueurs la mairie de Houdan met en
vente 30 places de stationnement situé
rue de la Tour les prix se situent entre
14000 et 16000 euros les recettes de
cette vente serviront ont remboursement
du pré relais de 1,4 millions d'euros
contractés en novembre dernier par la
mairie les futurs acquéreurs ont
jusqu'au 1er avril pour s'inscrire la
vente se fera au tirage au sort
[Musique]